guess what they are back for a family
vacation and we're celebrating jurors
day got a guy throwing it back to our
time with the GTL crew it's a show about
the Jersey Shore we don't we not
basically means that we like to take
care of ourselves we like to look good
it's pretty much a compliment our first
ET interview with the Jersey Shore cast
was back in 2009 at the time only three
episodes had aired and they were already
a cultural phenomenon
two weeks ago nobody knew you nobody
cared what's it like
I think we're changing the whole reality
the whole reality John we're not going
anywhere should probably get used to
these phases nearly 10 years later et
was on set in Miami for Jersey Shore
family vacation which premieres tonight
on MTV let's go back to the most iconic
Jersey Shore a moment of all time to
punch
I remember this guy to humor shots and I
was like getting annoyed that he was
doing her alcohol so I stood up to him
and that's when I got punched when I was
like cool this is my life
why am I here I always like to say that
I have no regrets but in Italy somehow
someway I made a huge miscalculation and
I head-butted the wall it was just
wasn't a good decision I would never
recommend any type of anything like that
ever again
[Music]